[Music]
how do you think
our universe began well
scientists have a creation story it's
not the same as the bible
it's not the same as other great
religious works it's a
a very hot dense state uh 13.8 billion
years ago
and as atlantis as it sounds there's
really a pile of evidence to support it
and in fact you know if i was being bold
i would say that the
status of the big bang is the theory of
science is right up there with darwin's
theory of natural selection
it's maybe not as commonplace knowledge
to most people that scientists think
they know how the universe started a
long time ago
but actually the evidence just keeps
piling up and it's really hard to avoid
the conclusion that
you know 100 billion galaxies and all
the stars and planets and people and
things they contain
were once squashed into an area smaller
than an atom
because that's basically what it says
and yet some scientists have the goal
to question it what are they seeing in
the theory that makes them think that it
is insufficient right well so there are
there are subtleties to it and you have
to dig a little deeper so
the basic picture that our universe was
smaller
hotter denser in the past and enormously
so i think that is really hard to refute
however this the full story of cosmology
has ingredients
in it that we think we have evidence for
where there's a lot more debate so
the universe is mostly made of dark
matter and dark energy and both of those
are puzzles to astronomers and to
physicists so
um you know it's fair enough to say well
you guys don't really know what you're
doing because there's all this dark
matter and it's more than all the
regular stuff and you don't know what it
is
although we've ruled out a lot of things
and we're kind of homing in on what it
might be
subatomic particle basically and then
dark energy where
truth be told all bets are off that's
the thing the entity that is causing the
universe to expand faster and faster at
an accelerating rate
and there's one very solid piece of
evidence that that's what the universe
is doing
but as for what's making it do it this
thing called dark energy
really we don't have much idea so that's
true there are pieces of this
picture of cosmology that are still up
for grabs or argued over
and so on but i would separate those out
from the basic picture of the universe
starting from a hot dense state it's
really hard to refute that
okay so the big bang is remains the best
explanation we have for the beginning of
the universe as we know it together
today
my question then is can it explain
how the universe started or does it only
work from a certain point on right we
sort of
we inevitably ask questions beyond what
we can explain
so the big bang does beg other questions
like what you said
where why did the universe start i mean
why
uh that great philosophers have said why
is there something rather than nothing
it's a pretty good question still
so what caused the big bang or what was
before the big bang or what was it
really like if
in this incredibly unfamiliar physical
state
and so you know the when scientists are
being
honest and you know not full of hubris
they acknowledge the limitations of
their theories but within those
limitations
you know they're fairly confident so the
big bang doesn't
give a reason for why it started doesn't
talk about the precursor state or what
was before
uh it doesn't say why science tends not
to answer why questions tends just to
answer how questions
so if we just limit it to saying the big
bang is a theory or model
that describes the evolution of the
universe over from a very very hot and
dense state 13.8 billion years ago it
does a
very fine job but when we ask those
deeper questions
we have trouble but it doesn't mean we
can't ask them i mean we might
hope for a better theory that actually
does answer those questions
now it won't be massively different
though because it's still got to
account for the fact that we see
evidence that the universe was smaller
hotter and denser in the past you can't
get around that
what what do you think the most
compelling theories
so the most compelling augmentations of
the basic picture
are the idea of inflation so there are
puzzles about the properties of the
universe that also beg for an
explanation
one is uh why is the universe so flat
space is flat
as well as we can tell very very close
to flat and then why should that be a
surprise well it's a surprise because
einstein's theory of gravity that ex
that accounts for the expansion of the
inverse
deals with curved space time and when
everything was all on top
of everything else spacetime should have
been very curved so there should be a
lot of curvature at the beginning and
yet it went away
or was stretched out and so inflation
was this idea
developed 40 years ago actually quite a
while ago
to posit a super fast inflationary
exponential
expansion in the first tiny fraction of
a second that essentially flattened out
space
also ensured that the universe would be
basically smooth
so the radiation of the universe is very
smooth the intensity is the same to one
part in
a thousandth of a percent in the sky
wherever you look so the inflation idea
accounts for those things which would
otherwise
not be naturally explained by the big
bang so that's a
that's the biggest embellishment or
augmentation of the big bang
now there are some other people who've
been trying to finesse away the
uh origin problem so the origin problem
is a problem like
what is this infinite density and you
know
infinite temperature what does that mean
of course it doesn't mean anything it's
non-physical
so there are a few modifications of the
big bang theory
that actually avoid they sort of finesse
away the big bang itself as a
singularity as a sort of infinite state
and they allow in practice actually for
a bouncing universe they bring back that
old idea
of an expanding universe that might one
day recollapse and then re-expand and
re-collapse so there's
there's some you know these are newer
ideas um
bouncing universes and so on again they
don't get they don't avoid the fact that
the universe we're living in right now
seems to have had a certain history that
we can measure but they place it in a
much larger context
where you don't have to have an origin
and that's it and it's part of a process
that may repeat and repeat which is an
interesting possibility
when you're talking about dark energy
you said that all bets are off
i don't know if you're a betting man or
not but where would you put your money
on
what it is you know it's it's off in the
sense that i wouldn't know where to put
my money with dark matter i know where
to put my money most people think
um you know just to digress into dark
matter for a while because it's not a
success in the sense that we know what
it is
but we've ruled so many things out that
it's narrowing what it could be if you
want to place your bets you've only got
a few choices
it's not black holes it's not uh planets
it's not rocks in space
it's not tiny dust particles we've ruled
out all the big dark stuff
pretty much down to subatomic particles
and luckily the physicists
in their own work on the standard model
of particle physics have thrown out a
few candidates that could
both explain some of the problems they
have in particle physics
and the problem of dark matter so that's
that
is progressing and there's a lot of
experiments to look for
dark energy is way more problematic
because
um this is like you know at the level of
high school physics or whatever
you you have evidence that the universe
is accelerating in its expansion so
something
that essentially works opposite to
gravity because gravity pulls things
together and this is making space
leap apart faster and faster that's what
dark energy is
so the phrase itself is just a phrase a
container for ignorance if you like
as far as what dark energy is there's
hundred literally hundreds of
theoretical papers
a year because the theorists are having
a lot of fun with this because the
observers haven't given them anything to
go on
that's the only good evidence for it is
that accelerating expansion
the theories go to string theory and
wild new theories of gravity that go
well beyond general relativity and
you know there's it's a wild west of
theory
um and it's very like i say in the bet
game it's
i wouldn't know how to place my bets
they sound wonderful it's like going
into an ice cream shop where they're
these thousands of wacky flavors and oh
which one do i taste you know which
one do i like i don't know they all look
good to me so
basically in science theory has to be
constrained you know the crazed dreams
of theorists have to be constrained by
observation and data and
we're in a very data poor situation for
dark energy that's the real problem
i'd rather be in the ice cream shop than
the wild west i think
but uh yeah we're gonna get both
metaphors um
you know for the lay person for the for
someone with
pre-university understanding of physics
what is dark energy
what is the problem that we're trying to
define and why is it proving so hard
so um the manifestation which is
you know why you believe it is worth
talking about at all is the accelerating
universe
and that that was doubtful for a while
it's 1990s mid-90s when that first
evidence came up
two groups competed with each other
vigorously over that
measurement it led to a nobel prize so
you know
very a lot of scientists think what they
saw was real and and
is actually happening um and then then
you
start to wonder well what is it so it's
a property of the vacuum apparently
it's not it's not a new particle per se
it's some
it's something to do with space-time
itself a property of the vacuum of space
so for a while you know immediately you
have a possible answer you go the
physicists go aha
the vacuum does have energy so it's been
known in quantum
theory and in you know in the world of
physics for a century
that the what we think of as the vacuum
empty space
actually has a tiny bit of quantum
energy that's part of quantum theory
it's very small um
and so you go through you chunk through
the math and you see well could this
tiny vacuum energy that we've known
about for a while in physics
could that account for could that be the
energy that's making space-time
accelerate in its expansion and when you
do the math
you get very excited as you start and
then when you do the math the number is
wrong
it's wrong by not like a factor of two
or fifty percent it's wrong by a hundred
orders of magnitude
and that's a big oops even in the
theoretical physics world
so the vacuum energy entity the thing
that we know of in physics that's a real
thing
of the vacuum fails miserably to account
for what the universe is doing and so
you go back to the drawing board and
that's why
you get the wild west of theories and
ideas because
because you're trying to you know you're
reaching for physics we don't know yet
and physicists know they have work to do
we don't think the standard model of
particle physics is the final answer
we've looked
since you know einstein spent 20 years
and physicists have spent another half
century trying to
merge gravity with quantum theory that's
the holy grail of physics
and so there's a thought that out of
that merger out of that unification
you know the answer to dark energy will
just drop into your lap
but there's actually no sign of that
happening yet so it's not clear that it
will
you touched briefly early on the fact
that scientists
provided they haven't got caught up in
hubris
will accept the limitations of their
theory do you think hubris has been an
issue in modern science
oh yes definitely it's always an issue
in science
um you know i mean this is a crass
analogy but you can't smell your own
farts you know so you just
you know people people who work on
especially theoretical physics they're
very smart i mean
this is rarefied air of mathematics and
physics
and um you know when they have successes
they're they're in they're amazing i
mean the standard model of particle
physics
itself led to a dozen nobel prizes over
a period of two decades i mean it really
was foundational work and so
so when physics at that level of
ultimate physics succeeds it's very
impressive
and i think that naturally can make
people a little overconfident
um and so physicists sort of they're not
all
monolithic some physicists are
you know suitably cautious about
theories and and skeptical
you know scientists should always be
skeptical uh some scientists perhaps are
not skeptical enough
in this arena and some scientists view
the track record they've got
as making them it probably does make
them overconfident about the projection
of theories into the future
um ed whitton who's you know been dubbed
the smartest man alive it's like one of
the things you know time magazine would
call a physicist that they interview i
mean he is a very smart particle
physicist
um he in a moment of true honesty and
and modesty he said you know we just may
not be smart enough to figure this stuff
out
by which he meant string theory or
unification of gravity and the other
forces
and and that so i don't know if that's
hubris but
the people doing an activity you know if
you're a painter or a musician
you don't like to be told well that's
impossible to paint you can't paint that
or well you can't pay play that scale or
that piece of music it's impossible
you know just give up don't even try so
scientists don't like to be told that
either they don't like to think it's
impossible that they couldn't do it
because they're not smart enough or
because we don't have the tools
sometimes we just don't have the tools
um
example on that uh general relativity
which is
you know incredible intellectual
achievement of einstein
um that language and that did not emerge
for a while after it could have or
should have because the tools did not
exist
einstein had to reach into the
mathematics of
crazy russian number theorists of the
19th century
for multi-dimensional curved space time
pure math he reached back into some pure
math that was lying on
the shelf in books and he molded it into
a physical theory
and so physicists often have to invent
their own tools or repurpose
mathematical tools before they can even
make progress on a problem
and you it's very hard to predict how
that's going to go in the future
uh let's build on that in a in a
slightly different way you've traveled
to india to teach science to buddhist
monks
i'm interested in the overlap between
buddhism and particle physics
where there is one right well before i
went on my first trip out there this is
now 10 or 11 years ago
you know i had in in my pocket you know
to read on the plane
uh dalai lama's universe in a single
atom and that was
a book he wrote i think in 1995 and it's
a it's a beautiful
exposition of you know the potential
alliance between buddhism and modern
science
you know and he doesn't overplay it
sometimes people force these things and
you can tell when they're forced he
didn't force it and he's learned
a lot from all the dialogues he's had
over the years so
i was excited by that to read his book
and then i was even more excited when i
realized
that down there on the ground in a
monastery
uh or nunnery we taught nuns as well as
monks um
that they were very savvy about physics
you know they not in a technical sense
um but they at the ideas level
so buddhist practitioners
in in the traditions that i was teaching
in
um they're exceptionally sophisticated
in their
ways of thinking about problems as
philosophers basically
and as logicians and rhetoricians so
they
um you know they are very able to
grapple with exactly the issues that
physicists have to grapple with too and
cosmologists you know where did the
universe come from and
what does mass mean and you know all the
foundational questions that scientists
are still they they
love that stuff they go straight there
whereas to be honest when i'm teaching
freshmen or 18 or 19 year olds they
sometimes get a little skittish about
that stuff i mean they're worried about
grinding through the math and and
solving the problem set that you just
gave them they don't really
go straight to the deep philosophical
questions but these monks and nuns boy
they go straight there
so you went there to teach them science
what did they teach you
um oh patience uh you know not an
imperfectly learned lesson
um you know they have a they have pretty
hard life i mean they're
they're poor it's dirt poor in northern
india where they're in
several settlement camps and so on
they've been given plots of
horrible land which is cheap land that
was available to them
um so they have a hard life get up at
four or five in the morning to pray and
you know and they're working through the
evening if they do academic stuff
they're working you know 17 18 hour days
so i i learned from them that you can be
intensely applied to whatever it is
you're doing whether it's
studying astronomy or your your prayer
tradition
um and be incredibly patient with it you
know just have
sort of infinite well of patience that's
just a really hard lesson to get
but also be immediately light not
take it so seriously that it squeezes
the fun out of life you know they're
they're never
far away from a smile or a giggle or
you know the whole class just sort of
breaking down and falling around in
laughter
over something that seemed pretty mild
to me i don't i don't even know what
triggers it sometimes
yeah sounds like something we could all
benefit from
yeah one of your recent books was
einstein's monsters the life and times
of black holes
what can black holes tell us about the
origin and the future of our universe
well probably more than we know at the
moment we're still learning about black
holes we don't know much
we know they exist i think the evidence
for black holes on a right
a range of scales not just the dead star
black holes but these huge black holes
at the center of galaxies it's really
good
uh and so nature knows how to make black
holes
as big as 30 billion times the mass of
the sun and
as small as a few times the mass of the
sun that's amazing
in the big bang and the story of our
universe
there's a fascinating chicken and egg
question of which came first the
galaxies or the black holes they all
contain
because it's possible that the early
universe was seated with primordial
black holes or
black holes that then aggregated matter
around them and that would be kind of
cool that would sort of
place back holes in the driver's seat as
being you know that
the instigators of all the building of
galaxies and things that we see in the
present-day universe
uh in terms of the end story they're
they're the last last man standing last
woman standing if you like because
when the universe is sort of dissipated
if it continues to accelerate in its
expansion as we expect it will
stars will all die you know boohoo no
stars
life doesn't have to die because there's
plenty of energy in the universe after
stars die
we can get gravitational energy from a
black hole for instance and in fact that
would be the final repository so
black holes are not quite immortal if
stephen hawking is correct eventually
they will evaporate and there will be
literally nothing left but the void
but for this long future of the universe
including the future
after stars are dead and it's a dark
universe all the all the action all the
fun is going to be where black holes are
and so i imagine these hypothetical
intelligent entities in the future of
the universe probably not us i don't
think will last that long
uh they'll be all black holes will be
where the action is they'll be all
huddled around black holes and whipping
energy out of black holes
get you know harvesting their spin to
power their civilizations and
doing weird imaging experiments with ben
uh space time around them and who knows
what they'll do black holes will be
you know the the center of the universe
in a
metaphorical sense when it's old do you
think by that time the big bang theory
will have been replaced
i mean there's a there's always a chance
that the big bang the whole the whole
thing is
rotten in the corn will collapse on
itself so you know
again if we're putting odds on it i mean
different people will put different odds
i know very confident people who just
think it's
essentially not conceivable that it's
wrong i mean i i'd put five percent odds
that it's wrong maybe 10
if i'm feeling nervous um but the q
the question is as a practical matter as
a scientist you have to know what you're
going to replace it with
and as theories get as theories mature
and get more sophisticated and have more
evidence behind them
the evidentiary bar that any succeeding
theory has to
clear gets higher and so it's not
you know it's not a question of whether
it's wrong or right i think
it looks right at the moment and we
don't have strong evidence that it's
wrong
but everyone who comes along every smart
young turk of
theoretical astrophysics who comes up
with a new theory
it's got a high bar to clear to explain
all that evidence that sits on the pile
of the big bang making everyone feel
pretty good that it's the theory of the
universe
and chris thank you so much for talking
to me that was fun thanks a lot
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv